sur les sujets de l'immigration et de
l'insécurité
il ya quand même un certain nombre de
points communs bon moi sur le plan
économique ou clairement il est beaucoup
plus libéral que je ne le suis mais sur
le plan de l'immigration et la sécurité
dont il a fait le coeur en réalité de
son de son de son projet il ya quand
même à ça les filles de soi vous avez
fait aussi pendant des années
oui on a beau fait venir oui mais
monsieur mais là moi je voudrais attirer
votre attention sur l'île nous on a
énormément parlé d'immigration quand le
constat sur l'immigration n'était pas
partagé par les français donc on s'est
battu pour faire admettre le constat il
ya un problème c'est une pas soit on
fait n'importe quoi c'est un art chic et
du coup ça entraîne des gros problèmes
mais aujourd'hui le constat il est
acquis c'est là où trouver leur peu sur
vous et rich lam et c'est là où la
candidature d'eric zemmour la question
qu'on se posait cd quelle plus value
apportée t-il quelle plus belle ce qui
vous a pas s qui est-ce qui vous a pas
dédiaboliser enfin la contrepartie c'est
aussi qu'il a caricaturé un certain
nombre de nos idées alors dieu merci on
a réussi à s'en à se séparer de cette
candidature mais le risque est là le
risque c'est l affaiblissement de nos
idées part à une forme de retour à une
caricature que nous avions aulas à
laquelle nous avions mis fin par le
travail par la précision de nos
propositions par le chiffrage de nos
propositions par la rédaction des
projets doit donc
ça reste quand même aujourd'hui je pense
un inconvénient les sondages l'ont dit
d'ailleurs si eric zemmour n'avait pas
été candidat je serais probablement
devant emmanuel macron dès le premier
tour ou bas ça change quand même les
chéris mais oui mon nom et vous allez
peut-être plus basse au premier tour
mais plus hautes au deuxième parce que
eric zemmour on va pas se mentir
aujourd'hui c'est ça qui est fou c'est
qu'on se dit eric zemmour s'est pour
l'heure la td ont ils dit souvent c'est
pire que marine le pen bah c'est à dire
que comme il a pris une pause ya un
positionnement caricatural du coup il a
contribué à ce que les français prennent
conscience que le projet qui était le
nôtre était un projet équilibré c'était
un projet raisonnable c'était un projet
de bon sens
donc oui en ce sens là peut-être at-il
avantage est en quelque sorte la la
capacité des français à nous voir tel
que nous sommes mais enfin il ya encore
des inconvénients mais ça sert à rien de
parler des avantages et des
inconvénients il a décidé de se
présenter après tout c'est la démocratie
et donc je n'ai rien d'autre à en dire
que eh bien on verra bien ce que cette
élection donnera